ALAN ARCHULETA ADKINS BABIES
BANKER FORGES BRADFORD BYRON
CORTESE DALLY DOT DURACELL
AIKMAN LASER GONZALEZ GROVE
HURTS BERG WHERE SO- HER TADO
JONES CAN MARKER LAYERED FLAVOR
THE MON. WIRE MELINDA'S MAN
NEWMAN NIELSEN CONTROL OF BOTH
PAM BORTON TINO RALPH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN BERGER WHAT KASKY. WEINER WELL. MEMBERS OF QUORUM
IS TO BUY COULD ASK TO PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLORIDA
THAT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED. WITH THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR CATALOGUER.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
UMBERG. SENATOR KAMMERER THANK
YOU. PRESIDENT AS WE END THIS
MONTH DEDICATED TO BLACK HISTORY
WE CONTINUE TO PRAY FOR RACIAL
HEALING. BASED ON PSALMS
NINETEEN AND ONE THIRTY NINE.
HOW CAN I DISCERN MY OWN INNER
RACISM LORD. CLEANSE ME I PRAY
FOR MY ID IN HIDDEN ERRORS OF
THINKING. ALSO I ASK THAT YOU
WERE STRAINING ME ANY
INTENTIONAL ACTS OF RACISM LET
NOT THE HABITS OF SYSTEMIC
RACISM RULE MY LIFE. POINT OUT
ANYTHING IN ME THAT IS HARMFUL
TO PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LEAD ME
INTO A NEW AND BETTER FUTURE
AMEN BASED ON. YES. COLLINGS IS
WE STAND TO PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
OUR FLAG WE STAND AS ONE NATION
. WITH THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE AND
WITH OUR ALLIES TO OPPOSE THE
AGGRESSION OF LEADING A PUTIN. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THERE HE'S RECALLING. AND YEAH
FOR ALL. THANK YOU FOR THAT
SENATOR UMBERG MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE BONE RESOLUTIONS
WILL BE PLACED ON TODAY'S.
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN ACR ONE TWENTY
SEVEN ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AC ARE
ONE TWENTY FOUR AND ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AC ARE ONE TWENTY EIGHT. MEMBERS ARE READY TO MOVE ON
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE WHEN YOU TAKE UP SENATE
THIRD READING ITEM NUMBER SIX
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD
RELATIVE TO BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
SENATOR BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND I RISE TODAY. THIS YEAR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WALK WALKERS
PRESENT THIS TO YOUR SIXTY SEVEN
IN RECOGNITION OF BLACK HISTORY
MONTH BUT REALLY. DOCU AMERICAN
HISTORY BLACK HISTORY SHOULD BE
SOUGHT CELEBRATED EVERY DAY. DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING ONCE STATED
FROM THE TIME YOU GET UP AND GO
TO WORK OR GO TO SCHOOL. AND
RETURN HOME YOUR LIFE HAS BEEN
IMPACTED. AND TOMATO TIMES BY
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY. THE
GENESIS A BLOCKAGE YOU MOUTH
BEGAN IN NINETEEN FIFTEEN. I
HAVE HALF A CENTURY AFTER THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT ABOLISHED
SLAVERY IN THE UNITED STATES
THAT SET TO SEPTEMBER HARVARD
TRAINED HISTORIAN CARTER G.
WOODSON. AND A PROMINENT MISTER
MINISTER JESSE E. MORELAND
FOUNDED TO ASSOCIATION OF STUDY
OF NEGRO LIFE AND HISTORY. AN
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
RESEARCHING AND PROMOTING
ACHIEVEMENTS OF BLACK AMERICANS
AND OTHER PEOPLE OF AFRICAN
DESCENT. KNOWN TODAY AS
ASSOCIATION STUDY OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN LIFE AND HISTORY THE
GROUP SPONSORED A NATIONAL.
NEGRO HISTORY WEEK IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SIX CHOOSING THE SECOND
WEEK OF FEBRUARY TO COINCIDE
WITH THE BIRTHDAYS OF ABRAHAM
LINCOLN AND FREDERICK DOUGLASS
TWO OF HIS HEROES MANY PEOPLE
SAID THAT FEBRUARY WAS CHOSEN
BECAUSE IT WAS THE SHORTEST
MONTH IN THE- YEAR. AND WANT TO
SHOW DISRESPECT AFRICAN
AMERICANS WITHOUT WAS THE
FARTHEST THING FROM THE TRUTH.
THE EVENT INSPIRED SCHOOLS IN
COMMUNITIES NATIONWIDE TO
ORGANIZE LOCAL CELEBRATIONS AND
ESTABLISH HISTORY CLUBS. AND
HOLDS PERFORMANCES AND LECTURES.
IN THE DECADES THAT FOLLOWED
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY BEGAN
ISSUING PROCLAMATIONS
RECOGNIZING NEGRO HISTORY WEEK.
BY THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES
THANKS IN PART TO THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND GROWING
AWARENESS OF BLACK IDENTITY
NEGRO HISTORY WEEK HEADED BALL
TO BLACK HISTORY MONTH. IN IT
GERALD FORD OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED BLACK HISTORY MONTH
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX CALLING
UPON THE PUBLIC TO SEIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR- DOT TWO
OFTEN NEGLECTED ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF BLACK AMERICANS. IN EVERY
AREA RAYMOND DEVER THROUGHOUT
OUR HISTORY OUR CONTRIBUTIONS IN
NOT JUST SLAVERY IS NOT JUST
FIGHTING FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IS NOT
EVEN SPORTS AND ENTERTAINMENT.
BUT PEOPLE OF ALL WALKS OF LIFE
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE HISTORY IN
THE FACE OF BRUTALITY. INJUSTICE
SINCE OUR ARRIVAL TO THIS
COUNTRY YET WE CONTINUE TO SERVE
AND CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY AT ALL
LEVELS. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THIS TIME TO SPECIFICALLY
HIGHLIGHT AN INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
CONCEPT CONTRIBUTIONS HAVE
CONTINUED TO BE FELT IN THIS
STATEAND COUNTRY FAR BEFORE HIS
OWN RIGHTS AS AN AMERICAN WAS
FULLY RECOGNIZE. THAT'S IN THE
PERSON OF FORMER SOME WOMEN.
WILLIAM BYRON RUMFORD. I
REMEMBER WAS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN ELECTED TO PUBLIC
OFFICE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND A MEMBER OF THIS BLACK
CAUCUS BAYERN RUN FOR WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN OH EIGHT IN CORTLAND
ARIZONA A GRADUATE OF UC SAN
FRANCISCO SCHOOL OF PHARMACY AND
A CERTIFIED PHARMACISTS ROCKFORD
ALSO EARNED A BA IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND A MA IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION BOTH. AT UC
BERKELEY. DUE TO HIS WEALTH OF
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE AND
POLITICAL INVOLVEMENT IN HIS
COMMUNITY PROFFER WAS ELECTED TO
THE ASSEMBLY IN NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT AND BECAME EFFECTIVE
LEGISLATOR ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
HE CREATED LEGISLATION TO CURB.
JOB DISCRIMINATION. IN SCHOOLS
ANY RACIAL BIAS IN THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD. AS
WELL AS A LAW THAT MADE IT
ILLEGAL FOR INSURANCE COMPANIES
TO REFUSE TO COVER BLACK
MOTORISTS. MOST NOTABLY MR TRUMP
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES
ACT IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE THAT
OUTLAWED DISCRIMINATION IN
EMPLOYMENT WHICH LED TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
FAIR EMPLOYMENT PRACTICE
COMMISSION HE ALSO AUTHORED AND
CHAMPIONED THE RUMFORD FAIR
HOUSING ACT SIGNED BY GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN SENIOR
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THAT
OUTLAWED DISCRIMINATION IN
HOUSING IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
THAT WAS UPHELD BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT. WHEN
IT RULED THAT PROPOSITION
FOURTEEN A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO INVALID INVALIDATE
THE ACT AND PREVENT HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL A YEAR LATER U.
S. IS SPRING COURT STRAIGHTEN
THIS RULING STATING THAT
PROPOSITION FOURTEEN VIOLATED
THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT AND THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SIX WHICH PROHIBITS ALL
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN THE
SALE OR RENTAL OF PROPERTY. THE
SACRIFICE AND FIGHT A BARN
ROUGHLY. WAS WILLING TO HELP ON
BEHALF OF BLACK CALIFORNIA'S LED
THE WAY FOR THE U. S. CONGRESS
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT DO NOT
THE NATIONAL HOUSING ACT WHICH
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBITS. HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION BY RACE COLOR
CREED NATIONAL ORIGIN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES IS
RICH WITH THEM. IN PERSON
INSPIRATIONAL STORIES OF NOBLE
MEN AND WOMEN LIKE BYRON
RUMFORD. WHOSE ACTIONS WORDS AND
ACHIEVEMENTS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
THE SUCCESS AND PROSPERITY OF
THIS COUNTRY AND THE STATE. THAT
WE SO OFTEN ENJOYED TODAY BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IS OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO REMEMBER
THOSE WHO ARE IN CONTINUED TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE TODAY. WE ALL
IN THIS COUNTRY BENEFIT FROM THE
RESILIENCE AND SACRIFICE MADE BY
COMMUNITY WHOSE WHOSE
HISTORICALLY ARE MARGINALIZED
AND HAVE LACKED ADEQUATE
REPRESENTATION. THAT IS ALL
CONTINUE TO OCCUR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THE NO BLACK HISTORY.
THE HONOR HISTORY. BY CONTINUING
THE WORK OF BYRON RUMFORD IN
IMAGES AND THEIR ALLIES AND
LET'S NOT BE FOOLED BY THIS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY. BLACK
HISTORY IS AMERICAN HISTORY. ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES. FOR THEIR COMMENTS
THAT WILL COME TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'LL VOTE
ON S. C. R. SIXTY SEVEN. SENATOR
PENN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
SENATORS I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. SIXTY SEVEN
AND I'M EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. S. CHAIR
OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY AND SUPPORT
OF S. C. R. SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
RECOGNIZES FEBRUARY IS BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. ONE MONTH IS
CERTAINLY IN NOT ENOUGH TO FULLY
CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY AND THE
MANY CONTRIBUTIONS BLACK
AMERICANS HAVE MADE THAT SET THE
FOUNDATIONS OF OUR NATION. AND
AS MY GOOD FRIEND SAID BLACK
HISTORY IS AMERICAN HISTORY. AND
CERTAINLY EFFORTS TO HIDE THIS
HISTORY. OR PREVENT THE TEACHING
OF THIS HISTORY TO OUR CHILDREN
DIMINISHES OUR COUNTRY. AS WE
CONTINUE TO LEARN AND CELEBRATE
BLACK HISTORY MONTH ONE THING
THAT ALWAYS STANDS OUT IS THAT
THE BLACK AMERICANS COMMITTEE'S
ABILITY TO INSPIRE AND
COLLABORATE AND LEAD. SHOULD BE
AN INSPIRATION TO US ALL.
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT OFTEN TALKED
ABOUT THE- BLACK COMMUNITIES AND
ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN TELLING
WORK TOGETHER TO COMBAT HATE AND
RACISM. AS MARTIN LUTHER KING
MARCHED FROM SELMA TO MONTGOMERY
ASIAN AMERICANS MARCHED WITH
HIM. AND ONE VINCENT CHEN WAS
BRUTALLY BRUTALLY TARGETED AND
MURDERED SIMPLY FOR BEING ASIAN
. THE BLACK COMMUNITY STILL DOES
ALONGSIDE THE API COMMUNITY AND
USE THEIR VOICES TO HELP ELEVATE
OURS. THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
DURING THE HEART OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTSMOVEMENT A COLLECTIVE OF
BLACK LATINO NATIVE AMERICAN AND
ATI COMMITTEES FOUGHT VIGOROUSLY
FOR WHAT WOULD EVENTUALLY
BECOME. ETHNIC STUDIES. AND
CERTAINLY WITHOUT THE BLACK
AMERICAN COMMUNITY WE WOULD NOT
BE WHERE WE ARE. HERE TODAY.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE.
INSPIRATIONAL BLACK LEADERS AND
TO ALSO REFLECT ON THE STRUGGLES
AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS. OF OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS BLACK AMERICANS
ARE THE BEDROCK OF AMERICAN
HISTORY AND ARTS AND CIVIL
RIGHTS LEGACY. THE FIGHT FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND EQUALITY ARE
CERTAINLY FAR FROM OVER. AND WE
SHOULD LOOK TO. BLACK LEADERS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH POLICIES
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR
COUNTRY AS A WHOLE AND THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE ALL. FELT STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE C. R. SIXTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. SENATOR DRAWS A.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS
CHAIR OF THE LATINO CAUCUS IT IS
MY HONOR TO RISE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HIS C. R. SIXTY SEVEN
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS AN
IMPORTANT TIME FOR US TO
CELEBRATE NOT THE ONLY TIME BUT
AN IMPORTANT TIME TO CELEBRATE
BLACK EXCELLENCE TO REFLECT ON
THE EXTRAORDINARY TALENTS
ACHIEVEMENTS AND CONTRIBUTIONS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS TO OUR
NATION. INDEED GENERATIONS OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS THROUGH WORDS
SACRIFICE AND ACTIONS HAVE MADE
IMMEASURABLE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE SUCCESS AND THE PROSPERITY
OF OUR STATE AND OUR NATION THE
STRUGGLES OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE BENEFITED AND INFLUENCED
THE LATINO COMMUNITY. FOR
INSTANCE THURGOOD MARSHALL'S
LEGAL WORK LEADING UP TO AND
INCLUDING HIS TIME ON THE
SUPREME COURT ESTABLISH CIVIL
AND POLITICAL RIGHTS THAT
CONTINUE TO EMPOWER ALL
MINORITIES AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
WELL HE MAY BE BEST REMEMBERED
FOR ARGUING AGAINST THE SEPARATE
BUT EQUAL DOCTRINE AND THE BROWN
VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION CASE
HE LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR
COUNTLESS LEGAL ADVANCEMENTS
THERE WOULD OCCUR OVER THE NEXT
FIFTY YEARS. ADDITIONALLY THE
VITAL WORK PERFORMED BY DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING AND HIS
COMMITMENT TO NONVIOLENCE
INSPIRED MANY FUTURE POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS TO SEEK SOCIAL CHANGE.
AMONG THOSE INFLUENCED BY DR
KING AND THE MOVEMENT WAS A
YOUNG SAYS R. CHAVEZ WOULD ALSO.
ACHIEVE SUCCESS FOR FARM WORKERS
AND ALL PEOPLE THROUGH NON
VIOLENT MEANS. THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IS GRATEFUL FOR SUCH
LEADERSHIP INSPIRATION AND
SUPPORT. IN TWO THOUSAND THREE I
WAS PRIVILEGED TO BE THE
NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF THE
IMMIGRANT WORKERS FREEDOM RIDE
ALONGSIDE REUBEN JAMES LAWSON
AND CONGRESSMAN LEWIS AS CO
CHAIRS. THIS WAS MODELED ON THE
NET THIS NATIONAL MOBILIZATION
WAS A PATH OF DEMAND IN THE
SUPPORT. A PATH TO CITIZENSHIP
FOR ELEVEN MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
OBVIOUSLY WAS MODELED ON THE
FREEDOM RIDES OF THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES. SO I'LL BE HALF OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS I EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS FOR ITS LEADERSHIP
IN THIS GREAT STATE THANK YOU.
SENATOR EDMUND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RISE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LGBT CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S. C.
R. SIXTY SEVEN TODAY WE HONOR
THE LIVES AND CONTRIBUTIONS AND
VOICES OF THE BLACK COMMUNITY IN
OUR NATION'S PAST PRESENT AND
FUTURE BLACK LIVES MANY OF WHOM
FOUGHT FOR THE RIGHTS WE HAVE
TODAY. THE BLACK COMEDIANS
LEADERS HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
MOVEMENTS SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
OUR COUNTRY WE UNDERSTAND THAT
BLACK ACTIVISM AS SO OFTEN BEEN
BORNE OUT OF NECESSITY SO THAT
BLACK PEOPLE CAN LIVE AND THRIVE
IN A NATION BUILT. BY THEIR
ANCESTORS. WE SEEK TO HONOR
BLACK LEADERS IS EXCELLENT AND
DRIVE HAVE BENT THE ARC OF THE
MORAL OF THE MORAL UNIVERSE
TOWARDS JUSTICE FROM THE
INCEPTION OF THE STONEWALL RIOTS
LED BY MARSHA P. JOHNSON. TO THE
PUSH FOR NATIONAL CIVIL AND
VOTING RIGHTS WERE DESTROYED BY.
BAYARD RUSTIN DO THE ARCHITECT
OF THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT. CO FOUNDER ALICIA
GARZA. TO BE IN THE GLOBAL FIGHT
AGAINST HIV AND AIDS BY PHIL
WILSON. THESE ARE BUT A FEW
EXCEPTIONAL BLACK FOLKS WILL
ALSO. CONTINUE TO MAKE A LASTING
POSITIVE. IMPRESSION IN THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY. WE IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY- INTERNALLY GRATEFUL.
TO THE BLACK COMMUNITY FOR
HELPING US LEAD THE WAY FOR A
BETTER TOMORROW. I ASK FOR YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. C. R. SIXTY
SEVEN. SENATOR WIENER. I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CHARACTERIZE- AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE- JEWISH CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF
A C. R. SIXTY SEVEN IF THERE'S
ONE THING THAT- WE KNOW IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY IT'S OUT WHEN
YOU FORGET YOUR HISTORY WHEN
PEOPLE FORGET YOUR HISTORY IT
HAS A WAY OF REPEATING ITSELF
AND SOMETIMES THAT MEANS THAT-
YOU GET KILLED YOUR COMMUNITY
GETS KILLED AND ATTACKING
GENOCIDE IS COMMITTED AGAINST
YOU BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
FORGOTTEN. HISTORY AND EVERY
YEAR WHEN WE COMMEMORATE AND
CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY MONTH-
SO. SOMETIMES IT CAN FEEL PRO
FORMA- AND SOMETIMES IT CAN FEEL
FOR SOME PEOPLE IT'S GOING
THROUGH THE MOTIONS AND IT
SHOULD NEVER FEEL THAT WAY BUT
SOMETIMES IT DOES. THIS YEAR. I
THINK WE ARE REMINDED ABOUT WHY
BLACK HISTORY MONTH. IS SO
IMPORTANT. WHEN WE LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
THIS COUNTRY. WHERE WE SEE
SCHOOL BOARDS AROUND THE COUNTRY
LITERALLY BANNING BOOKS TEACHING
BLACK HISTORY. LITERALLY BANNING
BOOKS TEACHING BLACK HISTORY
BANNING BOOKS TO TEACH ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST. ANY BOOKS TO TEACH
ABOUT THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY IN ONE
STATE THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
INCINERATING BOOKS. BURNING
BOOKS WHERE WE SEEN THAT BEFORE
. WE SEE LAWS BEING PASSED
AROUND THE COUNTRY LITERALLY
BANNING THE TEACHING OF BLACK
HISTORY I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN
LITERALLY BANNING THE TEACHING.
OF BLACK HISTORY. THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT IF WE DON'T LEARN AS
ADULTS AND CHILDREN ABOUT OUR
PAST AND NOT JUST A WHITEWASHED
PASS OF THE WHITE UNITED STATES.
OF ALL AMERICANS IN PARTICULAR
ABOUT THE HISTORY. OF OUR BLACK
COMMUNITY OF BLACK PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY IF WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO TEACH AND LEARN
ABOUT THAT IT GETS FORGOTTEN AND
THEN IT GETS REPEATED. SO BLACK
HISTORY MONTH THIS MONTH THIS
YEAR TAKES ON EVEN ADDITIONAL
IMPORTANCE. AS WE FIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT HISTORY IS TAUGHT
AND KNOWN AND ACKNOWLEDGED THANK
YOU. SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I RISE. IN
SUPPORT OF S. U. R. SIXTY SEVEN
IS THE CHAIR OF MILITARY
VETERANS COMMITTEE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I AM SO HONORED TO
SHARE WITH YOU. THE HISTORY. OF
THE MILITARY WE CALLED OBVIOUSLY
IT'S BLACK HISTORY MONTH BUT
LET'S TALK ABOUT MILITARY
HISTORY WHEN IT COMES TO AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THEIR SUPPORT OF
OUR GREAT COUNTRY. FROM THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR ALL THE WAY TO
THE CIVIL WAR- WE THINK OF WORLD
WAR TWO AND- THE BATTLES THAT
TOOK PLACE AFRICAN AMERICANS
WERE THERE SURE IN OUR COUNTRY.
SEGREGATED YES BUT THEY WERE
THERE IN SPITE OF IT THE
VOLUNTEER. FROM CITY TO CITY.
AND THEN OF COURSE FINALLY IN
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT WE'RE ABLE
TO JOIN EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND
WE BECAME TRULY ONE NATION ONE
RACE. ONE AMERICA. IT BUT IT'S
NOT OVER THE WORK IS STILL TO BE
DONE. BUT I'M SO PROUD OF WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE MILITARY. I
LOOK BACK IN I THINK OF ONE
INDIVIDUAL SERGEANT CARTER. WHO
WAS A TANK COMMANDER MORE WORK
TO RECEIVE THE MEDAL OF HONOR.
AND HE IS NOT THE ONLY ONE. IN
THE CIVIL WAR AFRICAN AMERICANS
RECEIVED AMERICA'S HIGHEST MEDAL
THE CONGRESSIONAL MEDAL OF HONOR
THEY HAVE TRULY DENNIS HONOR. I
MYSELF PERSONALLY IN MY OWN
FIRST FIREFIGHT TO THE RIGHT OF
ME TO THE LEFT OF ME WERE
AFRICAN AMERICAN BROTHERS IN THE
WITH THE EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE.
BROWN BROTHERS PROPER TROOPERS
SO I LOOK BACK AT WHAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED. JUST RECENTLY LAST
COUPLE THREE YEARS AGO WE HAD
THE LARGEST CLASS OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN WHO GRADUATED
FROM WEST POINT THE LARGEST
CLASS EVER IN HISTORY. SO IF YOU
WANT TO FOLLOW DIVERSITY YOU
WANT TO FOLLOW INCLUSION FOLLOW
OUR MILITARY AND ONE DAY MAYBE
WE WILL ALL BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
SO I STAND TALL WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES TO
SAY THANK YOUFOR STANDING UP.
AND ALWAYS REMINDING US WHAT
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS ALL
ABOUT. AND I TRULY SUPPORT YES
YOU ARE SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBER I STAND AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. U. R. SIXTY
SEVEN I THINK ARE CALLING FROM
GARDENA FOR BRINGING IT BEFORE
US. I'MIN READING ABOUT. THE
HISTORY OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
AND ARE PROBABLY GAVE US VERY.
GOOD AND ACCURATE- HOW IT
STARTED. AND INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH FEBRUARY WAS CHOSEN VERY
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE IT WAS THE
BIRTH. DATES OF BOTH- LINCOLN
AND FREDERICK DOUGLASS SO. THOSE
WERE ALREADY TWO BIRTHDAYS THAT.
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
CELEBRATED IN THAT OBVIOUSLY WE
TAKE NOTICE OF SO IF VERY GOOD
MONTH BUT- IT DIGITALLY. IT
TURNS OUT THAT EACH YEAR. BLACK
HISTORY MONTH CHOOSES THE THEME
AND THIS YEAR IT IS BLACK HEALTH
AND WELLNESS. AND IT'S A VERY
APT THEME BECAUSE- WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S STILL NOT STILL BUT JUST
ARE SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH. JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE
BLACK THE WEATHER IN CALIFORNIA
OR AMERICA THAT YOUR HEALTH
OUTCOMES ARE LOWER. AND IF WE
JUST WATCH WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PANDEMIC OUR- RESIDENTS OF THE
BLACK COMMUNITY WERE HIT FAR
HARDER IN TERMS OF MORTALITY
THAN- THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. AND THERE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS OVER THE LAST
DECADE OR SO BEGAN TO RECOGNIZE
THESE DISPARITIES AND FIGHT
THROUGH BUDGETARY AND OTHER
ACTIONS BEGIN TO ADDRESS THEM SO
LAST YEAR FOR EXAMPLE WE
INCREASED FUNDING. TO LOOK
SPECIFICALLY AT THE FACT THAT
BLACK BIRTHING PEOPLE IN BABIES
HAVE FAR HIGHER MORTALITY RATES
THAT NO MATTER WHAT THE
EDUCATION OR THE INCOME LEVEL OR
THAT THE HOSPITAL THAT THEY'RE
BIRTHING OUTCOMES AND FOR BOTH
THE- BIRTHING PERSON AND THE
INFANT. MORE LIKELY LEADS TO
DEATH. THAT IS NOT RIGHT NOT AT
THE POINT WHERE WE ARE IN IN
THIS- YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WITH THE TYPE OF MEDICAL
ADVANCEMENTS THAT WE HAVE AND SO
WE BOTH FIND IT MORE SPECIFIC
CARE FOR BIKE PARKING PEOPLE AND
RESEARCH ON WHY. SO THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS- GLADLY STANDS IN SUPPORT
OF S. U. R. SIXTY SEVEN AND
THANK YOU FOR BRING IT BEFORE US
. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. SEEING NONE SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS WHO SPOKE
ON THIS ISSUE AND THEIR
PERSPECTIVE AS TO THE IMPACT. OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN CONTRIBUTIONS
NOT ONLY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS NATION IN THE
WORLD AND I CAN TOUCH UPON
ALMOST EVERYTHING THAT WAS
STATED SPECIALLY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO WHO SPOKE TO
THE ALLIANCE OF. AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY IF WE KNOW OUR HISTORY
. WHEN THE JEWS WERE PROSECUTED
IN GERMANY AND THEY WERE.
FLEEING THEIR SCHOLARS EDUCATORS
WHEN THEY CAME TO AMERICA. IT
WASN'T HARVARD THAT WELCOME THEM
IT WAS A YALE WHO WAS IN
COLOMBIA. IT WAS IN U. S. C. H.
B. C. USE THAT'S WHERE THEY
FOUND EMPLOYMENT. THAT'S WHERE
THE EDUCATED AFRICAN AMERICANS
THAT'S WHERE THEY FOUND. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THEIR
CRAFT. AND AGAIN AS I SHARED
LAST YEAR WE TALK ABOUT WESTERNS
AND WE TALK ABOUT COWBOYS. IT
WAS IN THE WHITE GUYS WHO WERE
THE HEROES AND BROKE CATTLE IT
WAS THE BLACK COWBOYS. IT WAS
BASS REEVES IT WAS BILL PICKETT.
IT WAS NATE LOVE THOSE ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ON THE
FRONTLINES RISKING THEIR LIVES
EVERY DAY TO MOVE CATTLE ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY TO. BREAK COURSES
TO DO ALL THOSE THINGS SO WE CAN
HAVE FARMING RANCHING AND
AGRICULTURE. IN THIS COUNTRY AND
AGAIN THE NAME COWBOY WAS A
DEROGATORY REFERENCE TO BLOCK
FARMHANDS BECAUSE WHITES WERE
REFERRED TO. AS AND- BLACKS
REFERRED TO AS COWBOYS. AND WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT. AGAIN THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
WE'VE ALL GONE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
AND WE'VE ALL WENT BACK AND
FORTH ABOUT THE VACCINATION.
PLEASE NOTE. THAT IT WAS AFRICAN
AMERICAN. WELL WHO HAS BEEN. ON
THIS FAX FOR OVER FIVE YEARS. WE
CONTRIBUTE TO EVERY ASPECT OF
SOCIETY. AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
IT DESPITE CONTINUED HARASSMENT
RACISM AND EVERYTHING AND THIS
YEAR AGAIN WE'RE PROVIDING A
BOOK. TAKE A LESSON ON BLACK
ACHIEVERS AND HOW THEY MADE IT
AND WHAT THEY'VE LEARNED ALONG
THE WAY. AS ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
STATED IN SOME SCHOOLS YOU CAN
HAVE THIS BOOK. BECAUSE THE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY WE NEED TO
QUIT WHITEWASHING HISTORY
COLLEAGUES AND WE NEED TO STAND
FIRM AND TELLING THE TRUTH ABOUT
THE CONTRIBUTIONS. I'M NOT ONLY
AFRICAN AMERICANS BUT ALL PEOPLE
MY COLLEAGUE. BOB JUROR VETERAN
AFFAIRS MENTIONED THE
CONTRIBUTIONS AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE MADE. SINCE THE AMERICAN
REVOLUTION. BUT THE HELL
FIGHTERS WHO WERE FRONTLINE.
MILITARY MEN WHO WERE
DISCRIMINATED HERE AT HOME BUT
WENT AND PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE TO MAKE SURE WE CAN ENJOY
THE FREEDOMS THAT WE HAVE TODAY
AND I'LL JUST GIVE ONE MORE
EXAMPLE OF WE ALL HEARD THE
STORY. OF A MILLION AIRPARK THE
AMAZING WOMAN PILOT BUT HOW MANY
KNOWS THE STORY OF BESSIE
COLEMAN. I'M PRETTY SURE AND NOT
MANY PEOPLE KNOW THE STORY
BESSIE COLEMAN. THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO FLY.
SHE FLEW. IN NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE. BUT WEREN'T HISTORY BOOK TO
TALK ABOUT HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
BUT SHE WAS A- MARVELOUS PILOT.
WELL ACCOMPLISHED. A SKILLED
PILOT YOU COULD EVER. HOPE TO BE
IN A PLAN WITHIN THAT TIME IN
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE VERY LITTLE
IS TALKED ABOUT. HER
CONTRIBUTIONS. AND AS ALL OF YOU
KNOW. I'M NOT A GOLFER. AND. ANY
TIME YOU TEE UP A BALL ON A GOLF
COURSE PLEASE NOTE THAT WAS
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN AT THE
GOLF T. AND WHEN YOU GET IN AN
ELEVATOR TODAY. I BELIEVE THIS
BUILDING PLEASE KNOW THAT IT WAS
AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO INVENTED TO
ELEVATOR AND AS DR KING STATED
OUR LIVES ARE IMPACTED NUMEROUS
TIMES FROM THE TIME WE GET UP TO
THE TIME WE GO TO BED BY THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS SO. ON THAT NOTE
MEMBERS I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE ON A C. R. SIXTY
SEVEN BECAUSE I CAN BE HERE
UNTIL THE COWS COME HOME TALKING
ABOUT ALL THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO
THIS COUNTRY THAT. MANY OF US
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT SO I.
SHE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY NOT
ONLY THIS MONTH BUT EVERY DAY TO
LEARN THE CONTRIBUTIONS I
RESPECT S. ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN EYE ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS I BASE FIVE BECKER HI
FORGES. BY BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM I PROTESTING HI DARLING.
FIVE DOT I THE RUSSELL HI ADNAN
I GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HI GROVE
. HERTZBERG I WENT SO HI HER
TADO JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LATER I THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I GO TO A VOTE
I PAN HI FOUR TWENTY NINE HI
RALPH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN
I AM BERG ALL RIGHT HI MY
CUSTODY I WINNER I WILL. PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. GROVE
HER TADO WELL. I THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA
SEE A SHORT VIDEO THAT'S BEEN
PREPARED SPECIALLY FOR TODAY.
OWNING A HOME IN CALIFORNIA IS
JUST AS ELUSIVE TODAY FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS AS IT WAS IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE. IN SAN
DIEGO ONLY 29% OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS OWN THEIR OWNHOMES
COMPARED TO MORE THAN 61% OF
WHITES IN THAT CITY. AND THE
GAFFER SIMILAR IN MOST REGIONS
OF CALIFORNIA AND YET OWNING A
HOME IS MORE THAN AN AMERICAN
DREAM LIKE FOOD AND CLOTHING
SHELTER IS INTENSITY THAT TOO
MANY OF OUR FELLOW CITIZENS
SIMPLY DO NOT POSSESS. FOLLOWING
WORLD WAR TWO THERE WAS A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN NUMBER OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST THEY LIVED IN PUBLIC
HOUSING PROJECT THERE ARE MANY
NEIGHBORHOOD DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST BLACKS IN CALIFORNIA. I
WROTE FOR SUBURBAN. IN THE MID
FORTIES AFTER WORLD WAR TWO.
ABOUT WHAT TO DO WITH. NOT ONLY
A POLITICAL FIGURE BUT ALSO A
BUSINESSMAN AND SOMEONE WAS
INVOLVED IN NEIGHBORHOOD OTHER
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS BUT
FRANKLY JUST A REALLY NICE
PERSON. BUT I WAS REALLY DO THAT
PIONEER WHO MADE EFFORT. BRING
THE ICE AND POLITICS CAL BECAME
THE FIRST BLACK MEMBER TO LEAD
FROM NORTH CALIFORNIA. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE PASSED A
FAIR HOUSING ACT. AUTHORED BY
THE HONORABLE BYRON RUMFORD. WHO
REPRESENTED THE OAKLAND BERKELEY
EAST BAY AREA OF CALIFORNIA THE
LEGISLATION AIMED TO ELIMINATE
REDLINING DISCRIMINATION AND
RACIST POLICIES PREVENTING
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND OTHER
RACIAL MINORITIES FROM
PURCHASING HOMES. IN ROMFORD
ACTIVE. WHICH GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN UP. THE
ENTIRE LOS ANGELES. PERSON WHO
COULD AFFORD TO LIVE WHERE EVER
THEY COULD AND COULD ENJOY ALL
OF THE BENEFITS OF MOVING WHERE
THEY WANTED TO. WHERE YOU LIVE
CAN HAVE TREMENDOUS IMPACT. ON
YOUR QUALITY OF LIFE AND YOUR
OPPORTUNITY BUT WE TAKE IT AWAY
IT'S VERY PERSONAL. IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
PASSED AROUND FROM ACTING EVEN
THOUGH- SOMEONE. SUCCESSFUL IT
WAS A LOT OF OPPOSITION THEACT
WAS EVENTUALLY OVERTURNED BY A
STATEWIDE INITIATIVE THAT GROUP
CALIFORNIA STILL WASN'T PREPARED
ALL OF THE CITIZENS IN THE
AMERICAN DREAM. MOST REMARKABLE
ABOUT BY ROAD FROM WHICH
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS AGAINST THE
ODDS BUT THE FACT THAT THERE WAS
NOT AN OVERWHELMING. DEMOCRATIC
OR REPUBLICAN BASE FOR ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS IS
INDICATIVE OF POLITICAL HEARD
THAT NATURE EXIST IN MODERN
SOCIETY. IN APRIL OF NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT PRESIDENT LYNDON B.
JOHNSON SIGNED THE FAIR HOUSING
ACT WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
U. S. HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT THE
ACCESS HOUSING DISCRIMINATION.
IS ILLEGAL IN NEARLY ALL
HOUSING. WE HAD LEAD REALLY NEED
TO CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT THE
WAYS THAT WE CAN ENABLE THE
BLACK COMMUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD CREDIT. ACCESS TO CAPITAL
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO OWN THEIR OWN HOMES
WE KNOW THAT EVEN IN THIS DAY
AND AGE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RACISM. HAS KEPT THE
BLACK COMMUNITY FROM BEING ABLE
TO OWN OUR OWN HOMES. WE KNOW
THAT'S COME IN THE FORM OF
REDLINING IT'S COME IN THE FORM
OF COVENANTS AND RESTRICTIONS
THAT HAVE CAUSED US NOT TO BE
ABLE TO EVEN LIVE OR- BUY HOMES
IN PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES. AND
WE STILL SEE THE LEGACY OF RED
LINING. THE ROCKFORD ACT WAS
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY. BECAUSE
AT THAT TIME YOU COULD BE
DISCRIMINATED IN PUBLIC HOUSING.
IN FACT IT COULD BE
DISCRIMINATED IN MOST PUBLIC AND
CIVIC INFRASTRUCTURES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
ROCKFORD'S CURRY. AND BRAVERY IN
FIGHTING THE PAST ACT NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE LAID THE FOUNDATION.
FOR A WHOLE HOST OF SOCIAL
CHANGE AND INCLUSION ACROSS OUR
CIVIC AND PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE.
ACTS LIKE RUN PROJECT WE HAVE A
MODEL FOR HOW WE CAN FIGHT BACK.
AND HOW WE CAN USE POLICY AS A
TOOL TO CHANGE THE CONDITIONS OF
LIFE. FOR PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
AND PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE FACING FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION. IN ORDER FOR
MORE AFRICAN AMERICANS TO OWN
HOMES WE NEED OUR BANKING
INSTITUTIONS TO BE MORE.
GENEROUS AND PEN AND THEIR
PROCESSES OF PROVIDING LOANS TO
AFRICAN AMERICANS WE'VE SEEN
THROUGH THE- DATA THAT AFTER A
MERICAN. HOME LOANS AT A RATE OF
ALMOST 50% LESS. THAN OUR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS SO IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
PHONES. EVEN THOUGH WE'VE GOTTEN
RID OF RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS AND
REDLINING SOME OF THOSE
PRACTICES SUCH AS FISH STILL
EXISTS TODAY SO. WE HAVE TO
DRESS UP AS WELL. I WITHIN MY-
IT'S ALWAYS DONE. MOVING FORWARD
AND AGREE OF GREATER. POWERFUL
MESSAGE FROM THE BLACK CAUCUS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR- PRODUCING
THAT IN BRINGING INFORMATION
FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN BE
EDUCATED ABOUT THINGS WE
FORGOTTEN OR THAT WE SHOULD KNOW
MUCH BETTER. MEMBERS THAT
CONCLUDES ITEM NUMBER SIX WE'RE
READY TO MOVE ON TO THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IS ITEMS
ELEVEN THROUGH THIRTEEN IS THERE
ANY MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT. SEEING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTIONS ONE TWENTY SEVEN ONE
TWENTY FOUR AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS I BASE HI BRECHER I
FORGES HI BRADFORD HI BYRON I
PROTESTING I DALLY FIVE DOT. I
TORONTO HI ADNAN FIVE LASER HI
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE
HERTZBERG HI WESSEL HI HER TADO
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. HI
LABOUR HI THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN HI CONTROL OF BOTH HI
PAM. I FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT
HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN HI
AMBER I LIKE HOW SKI. I WINNER I
WILL. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. GROVE HER TADO
MELINDA'S WELL. I THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO AND ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN ICE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO ON DECK
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
EDMUND. A BUDGET SUB THREE WILL
MEET IN FORTY TWO OR THREE AT
TEN AM. BUDGET SEPT THREE FORTY
TWO OH THREE SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI. THANK YOU MADAM PRESENCE
THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL BE IN
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. BY DECEPTIVE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. VERY GOOD
. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE TIME FOR OUR EDURNE IN
MEMORIES. MADAM PRO TEM. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH I
RISE TO ADJOURN TODAY IN MEMORY
OF CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER MORRIS
KASUT HO WHO DIED ON FEBRUARY
ELEVENTH AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
NINE. BORN IN NEW YORK CITY IN
NINETEEN FORTY TWO MORRIS CAME
TO SAN DIEGO IN THE SEVENTIES.
CHARGED WITH THE TASK OF HELPING
OUR COMMUNITY FIGHT ANTI
SEMITISM BIGOTRY AND HATE. AN
IMPORTANT BUT HEAVY ROLE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY KEPT HIM BUSY
UNTIL HIS RETIREMENT IN TWENTY
TEN. AND PUT HIM AND HIS FAMILY
AT RISK NUMEROUS TIMES OVER FOUR
DECADES. DESPITE THE FACT THAT
HE WAS NOT A STRANGER TO A
BULLET RESISTANT VEST. HE WAS ON
THE RECEIVING END OF BOMB
THREATS AND PAINTED SWASTIKAS
AND HE WAS TARGETED BY WHITE
SUPREMACISTS. MORRIS DEVOTION TO
HIS WORK NEVER WAVERED. HE WAS
FUELED BY DREAM THAT HIS EFFORTS
COULD MAKE A BETTER SAFER PLACE
AND THEY DID. CERTAINLY FOR SAN
DIEGO. AS THE FOUNDER AND
REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF OUR LOCAL
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE MORRIS
WAS A FIXTURE OF SAN DIEGO'S
JEWISH COMMUNITY AND A GIANT IN
THE FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IN
THE REGION. HE GUIDED SAN DIEGO
IN THE AFTERMATH OF MULTIPLE
ANTI SEMITIC ATTACKS HELP TO
PROTECT OUR MUSLIM NEIGHBORS IN
THE WAKE OF NINE ELEVEN. AND
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO REDUCE THE
ACTS OF HATE THAT HAVE TOO OFTEN
MARRED OUR COMMUNITY. UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE CREATED A HATE CRIME
REGISTRY. INTERFAITH WORKSHOPS
AND TOLERANCE TRAININGS. OVER
THE YEARS MORRIS WORK CLOSELY
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. WAS ACTIVE
ON COMMITTEES FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING ANTI SEMITISM. AND
BECAME KNOWN AS THE PERSON TO GO
TO WHEN BIGOTRY OF ANY SORT
REARED ITS UGLY HEAD. HIS
PASSION WAS ADMIRABLE HIS
UNRELENTING OPTIMISM WAS
INSPIRING. AND A SENSE OF HUMOR
WAS ALWAYS SHARP. HIS LEGACY ONE
DOOR IN THE REMARKABLE WORK THAT
FOREVER CHANGED OUR COMMUNITY.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
FIFTY YEARS DURING. HIS SONS
LOREN AND SIMON HIS BROTHER
STEVE HIS SISTER SUSAN AND ONE
GRANDCHILD COLLEAGUES ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN RECOGNITION OF MARS
CONCERT SO THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEMP PLEASE BRING HIS NAME TO
THE DESK SO HE CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR ALAN.
MEMBERS WE JUST HAD A WONDERFUL
DISCUSSION OF THE MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO. ERIC IN LIFE AND I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE WHAT A ONE
PARTICULAR AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO
REALLY LEFT HER MARK ON OUR
COMMUNITY IN OUR NATION AND
WHOSE LIFE WAS CUT SHORT IN A
BRUTAL MANNER. LIKE TO RISE IN
IT TO TURN THE MEMORY OF MR MRS
JACQUELINE. A LOT. JACKSON WAS
VERY POORLY SHOT DURING. A
HORRIFIC BOTCHED OME. INVASION
ROBBERY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AT OUR HOME IN BEVERLY
HILLS AND PASSED AWAY ON
DECEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY ONE. SHE
WAS BORN ON MARCH SIXTH NINETEEN
FORTY JAMAICA QUEENS IN NEW YORK
SHE BEGAN HER CAREER AS- A
HOSPITAL TACKING PHLEBOTOMIST IN
OUR TWENTIES WHILE ALSO
SUPPORTING YOURSELF BY MODELING
AND WORKING. WITH THE EBONY
FASHION FAIR. BECAUSE DURING
THIS TIME THAT SHE MET HER
HUSBAND CLARENCE. AVON THE
LEGENDARY MUSIC EXECUTIVE AND
FILM PRODUCER THEY MOVED
TOGETHER FROM NEW YORK TO
BEVERLY HILLS IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE QUICKLY BECAME. ADORED
AND RESPECTED MEMBERS. OF THE LA
COMMUNITY. EVERYBODY TALKED TO
WHO KNOWS THEM KNOWS HOW. BRIGHT
AND- VIVACIOUS. AND CHARISMATIC
THEY WERE AND THEY THREW
THEMSELVES INTO HELPING OTHERS-
JACQUELINE'S PASSION ABOUT
HELPING OTHERS WAS SHE WAS A
HEARTFELT. PHILANTHROPIC LEADER
SHE ADVOCATED FOR THE ARTS FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS FOR CHILD WELFARE
FOR EDUCATION. SHE WAS FOR
PRESENT NEIGHBORS FOR WHAT I
NEED MEMBERS OF WATSON SUPPORT
THE SOUTH CENTRAL COMMUNITY
CHILD CARE CENTERS TO SERVE ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS AT UCLA'S
INTERNATIONAL STUDENT CENTER.
WELCOMING STUDENTS FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD TO STUDY. THERE SHE
BECAME A FOUNDING MEMBER OF
UNIVERSITIES RATE RATE TREATMENT
CENTER. HER LOVE OF THE ARTS
RANDI. SHE SERVED ON THE BOARD
OF PACIFIC ASIA MUSEUM IN
PASADENA THE LA COUNTY MUSEUM'S
EAST ASIAN ART COUNCIL'S USE
ABOARD PRESIDENT OF THE MUSEUM
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN ART IN LOS
ANGELES AND CLOSER TO HOME SHE
WAS A LONG TIME A VERY ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE WALLIS ANNENBERG
CENTER FOR PERFORMING ARTS AT
BEAUTIFUL FACILITY. AT THE OLD
POST OFFICE IN BEVERLY HILLS.
JACKSON SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND
OF FIFTY FOUR YEARS OUR TWO
CHILDREN ALEXANDER NICOLE THERE
HER SISTER JEAN MORRIS MANY NEST
NIECES AND NEPHEWS AS WELL.
HORRIFIC EVENT THAT TOOK HER
AWAY FROM US AND- I JUST ASKED
HER MEMORY CONTINUE BLESSING FOR
ALL OF US. PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IT IS WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
JONATHAN FLAGLER WHO SADLY LOST
HIS LIFE IN THE LINE OF DUTY ON
JANUARY SIXTH A RESIDENT OF SAN
CLEMENTE JONATHAN WAS A TWENTY
ONE YEAR VETERAN OF THE
FIREFIGHTING PROFESSION FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS JONATHAN WAS A
CREW MEMBER FOR FIRE STATION
EIGHTY THREE OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT. PRIOR TO
JOINING THE COUNTY JONATHAN
SERVED AS A FIREFIGHTER FOR THE
CITY OF VERNON FOR NINETEEN
YEARS WHILE RESPONDING TO A
HOUSE FIRE ON JANUARY SIXTH
JONATHAN WAS GRAVELY ENERGY
INJURED AND RUSHED TO HARBOR
UCLA MEDICAL CENTER WHERE HE
REGRETTABLY SUCCUMBED TO HIS. IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JENNY THEIR
TWO SONS BRODY AND JACK. MANY OF
JONATHAN'S FRIENDS AND FAMILY
DESCRIBED HIM AS A DEVOTED
HUSBAND AND FATHER WHO HAD A
FANTASTIC SENSE OF HUMOR. HE WAS
ALSO HIGHLY RESPECTED BY HIS
COLLEAGUES AND WAS SAID TO TRULY
EMBODIES THE CORE VALUES. OF THE
LA COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT LARRY
MINOW WHO WORKED ALONGSIDE
FLAVOR FOR NEARLY TWENTY YEARS.
GIVE A DEEPER LOOK INTO THE MAN
THAT JONATHAN FLAGLER WELLS IN
THE MEMORY THAT WILL LIVE ON HE
SAID HE WAS PRACTICAL HONEST
FAIR. BUT ALSO HE WAS A
FIREFIGHTERS FIREFIGHTERS. I
WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND OUR
CONDOLENCES AND PRAYERS TO THE
FAMILY. AS THEY MOURN THIS
ENORMOUS LOSS AN ASSET WE
ADJOURNED TODAY AND THE MEMORY.
OF JONATHAN FIDLER THANK YOU.
SENATOR ON. ONE OF MY COLLEAGUE
IN THE TURNING IN MEMORY OF
JONATHAN FLAGLER HI HE WAS A
CONSTITUENT OF OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY BUT HE DIED
FIGHTING A FIRE SERVING THE
COMMUNITY THAT I REPRESENT
RENTED HOUSE FOR EIGHTIES. AS
WAS MENTIONED HE WAS A TWENTY
ONE YEAR FIREFIGHTER SERVED IN
THE RING OF FIRE DEPARTMENT FOR
NINETEEN YEARS HE TRANSITIONED
OUT COUNTY FIRE AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. HE WAS A WELL
KNOWN HIGHLY REVERED FIREFIGHTER
WHOSE SPIRIT AND SMILE BRIGHTEN
ANY ROOM HE ENTERED. FROM MY
BEST UNDERSTANDING HE'S
DESCRIBED BY MY COLLEAGUE THIS
IS BEING A TRUE EMBODIMENT OF
FIREFIGHTING VALUE SHOWCASING
COURAGE COMMUNITY COMMITMENT
INTEGRITY TEAM WORK. IN ALL
AREAS OF HIS LIFE. AND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF HIS DEATH I
THINK. UNDERSCORES THIS. ON THE
MORNING OF JANUARY SIXTH OF THIS
YEAR. HE AND HIS TEAM RESPONDED
TO A HOUSE FIRE IN RANCHO PALOS
VERDES AS I MENTIONED IN THE
SOUTHERN PORTION OF MY DISTRICT.
THEY INSURE THE SAFETY THE
FAMILY THEY HAD THEY GOT THE
WHOLE FAMILY OUT. OF THE HOUSE.
AND JOHN THEN WENT BACK INTO THE
HOUSE TO TRY TO PREVENT FURTHER
DAMAGE TO THE- TO THE HOME. AND
UNFORTUNATELY HE WAS OVERCOME BY
SMOKE AND FLAMES. AND AFTER
BEING RUSHED TO THE HOSPITAL HE
SUCCUMBED TO HIS INJURIES AND
DIED. IN THE HOSPITAL. I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW HOW MUCH THE ENTIRE
HOUSE FOR HIS COMMUNITY- MOURNS
HIS. HIS DEATH AND THEY'RE SO
TOUCHED BY HIS SELFISHNESS IN A
SENSE OF SACRIFICE. IT WAS VERY
TRAGIC DAY FOR OUR COMMUNITY
WILL WILL WILL LIVE ON BOTH IN
ORANGE COUNTY WITH HIS. FELLOW
WITH HIS FAMILY BUT ALSO IN LA
COUNTY WITH THIS FELLOW
FIREFIGHTERS AND ALL THE FOLKS
WHOSE LIVES HE SAVED THROUGHOUT
HIS ILLUSTRIOUS CAREER. THE
SERVICE IS TESTAMENT. TO THE
PROFOUND IMPORTANCE OF
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE STATE. WE
SHOULD NEVER LOSE SIGHT OF THESE
HEROES. AND I JUST LIKE TO JOIN
MY COLLEAGUES IN MOURNING HIS
LOSS JOHN THE FLAG WITH. SENATOR
BATES SENATOR ALAN PLEASE BRING.
HIS NAME FOR TODAY SO HE CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR OCHO BOAT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS. MADAM
CHAIR I RISE IN INSURANCE IN
MEMORY OF DR MARGARET HILL WHO
WAS A CONCISION AND DEAR FRIEND
OF MINE FROM SUNBURN DINO THEN
DR MARGARET HILL WAS A BOARD
MEMBER AND PAST PRESIDENT THE ST
BERNARD DINO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT DURING HER TIME AS AN
EDUCATION LEADER SHE
PASSIONATELY ADVOCATED FOR
CHILDREN. IN THE WORDS OF DR
SCOTT WYATT WHO WAS CLOSE TO HER
DOCTOR HILL WAS LOVED FOR HER
WARM HEART INFREQUENTLY
ENCOURAGED EDUCATORS TO MOTIVATE
KIDS WITH MORE HUGS THAN TUGS WE
ARE BETTER BECAUSE SHE LED WITH
STRENGTH LOVE AND COMPASSION FOR
EVERYONE. SHE WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WOULD
RECEIVE AN EDUCATION BASED ON
ACADEMIC JUSTICE AND BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS. AS THE DAUGHTER OF A
SHARECROPPER SHE WORKED GRUELING
THE LONG DAYS ON THE FARM TO
ENSURE HER FAMILY DIDN'T STARVE.
AND THEN SHE WOULD WORK LATE
INTO THE NIGHT TO KEEP ON HER
SCHOOLING. FROM HER PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES DR HELLO UNDERSTOOD
THE IMPORTANCE OF MEETING
STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE RATHER
THAN TURNING TO HARSH ULTIMATUMS
TO PRODUCE SUCCESS. HER STRENGTH
AND TENACITY MADE HER A
BEAUTIFUL INFLUENCE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. AND HER NO EXCUSES.
NO EXCUSES ATTITUDE INSPIRED
EVERYONE WHO WAS FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO MEET HER. THANK YU
FOR ALWAYS SHARING YOUR TIME
WITH THEM WITH ME HE WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED. BUT YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR COMMUNITY
WILL NEVER EVER BE FORGOTTEN.
PLEASE BRING HER NAME TO THE
DESK SO THAT SHE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. MEMBERS IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU ALL FOR
THIS WEEK OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AT TWO PM THANK YOU. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT TWO PM.